bom dia é prolongar muito obrigado pelo
convite o presidente da ump é importante
é melhor filme eu sou professor de
física e eu tenho um relacionamento
muito interessante e educação
eu fui aluno de escolas públicas a vida
inteira fundamental em escolas públicas
é fundamental 2 e médio universidade e
comecei a dar aula no ensino privado e
começou a incomodar um pouquinho na
verdade dando um passo para trás
quando terminei ou à escola eu fui
estudar medicina e foi bacana pra
família porque é eu ia ser o primeiro
médico da família inteira minha mãe
chorou nós nos abraçamos eu fiz
faculdade durante mais ou menos seis
meses e resolvi sair da faculdade de
medicina
a minha mãe chorou nós nos abraçamos
eu passei algum tempo tentando descobrir
o que eu queria fazer eu saí da medicina
com ênfase em engenharia depois eu fui
fazer economia depois de fazer
matemática depois eu ando em todas as
faculdades e no meio desse caminho todo
me via o tempo todo dando aula e é muito
interessante para mim é não consegui me
achar como o aluno e me achar também
como professor foi uma coisa que sempre
foi um pouco esquisita pra mim não
conseguia descobrir qual é o meu lugar
como aluno e um lugar no final das
contas da alma ela ser professor
o fato não ter passado a vida inteira em
escolas públicas etanol em escolas
particulares começou a incomodar um
pouquinho até que chegou um ponto que eu
acho que eu tenho que parar de fazer o
que está fazendo e fazer alguma coisa é
para dar aula em escolas com as colas
caríssimas é e tentava um pouco mais de
escala para a educação foi um pouquinho
sobre escala sobre impacto é e quando
quando nós decidimos parar tudo e montar
o descomplica montar um site de educação
é muito importante para tentar entender
o que você vai fazer e é muito
importante para tentar entender o que
você não vai fazer mal a primeira coisa
que nós começamos a decidir o que nós
não vamos fazer o que nós não vamos ser
o que nós não vamos tentar conquistar
por mais estranho que possa parecer o
que nós definimos é que nós não vamos
revolucionar a educação anos que estamos
não vão representar um site educação e
vocês não vão revolucionar a educação
não existe uma educação que funciona e é
o nosso nessa missão o nosso desafio era
vá à educação que funcionam com milhões
de pessoas e não criar uma outra do zero
ignorar tudo o que foi feito
existe um histórico que funciona na
educação
e ele faz para um pouquinho parte dele
eu dou aula 17 anos
eu gosto de acreditar que existem coisas
que são boas
existem coisas que funcionam bem existem
professores maravilhosos no brasil eo
nosso maior desafio é fazer isso ser
acessível para todo mundo
nós não vamos nós não iríamos não vamos
ainda não descomplica responsável pela
escola repensar o papel do professor
destruir tudo o que foi feito de bom
mas não vamos fazer nada disso mas nós
vamos sim melhorar muito a vida dos
alunos
nós podemos melhorar muito o dia a dia
dos alunos nós podemos melhorar muito o
dia a dia escolar dos alunos e dos
professores também sem ter que continuar
esquecer tudo que foi feito de ball nos
mas centenas de anos
nós podemos fazer isso de maneira
simples o que eu queria falar um
pouquinho aqui é como a gente pode pegar
a educação e transformar a educação é
uma coisa um pouquinho mais simples
há um tempo atrás eu recebi um relatório
sobre o futuro da educação e o que a
educação seria no futuro e esse é isso
aí o relatório elaine publishing e 2.0
em tons devassas vls lcms eu dou 17 anos
eu demorei um tempo para descobrir o que
está fazendo porque não sabe o que está
fazendo você entender isso e nós
precisamos então parar a dar um passo
por raios
então tá resolver educação de maneira um
pouco mais simples
será que não dá pra fazer isso sem ter
que entender todo essa arquitetura e
descobrir onde você está e tentar se
encaixar num possível revolução que você
vai tentar fazer parte disso
só não pode não pode procurar de toda
maneira simples ea resposta sim isso é
possível
isso é possível é possível simplificar
as coisas não é pouco o nome do site
descomplica é possível tentar
simplificar as coisas pôr se você pensar
que você precisa fazer quatro coisas
você precisa criar conteúdo de qualidade
você precisa arrumar boas maneiras de
distribuir seu conteúdo
fazer esse conteúdo chegar nas pessoas
fazem esse conteúdo chegar nos alunos
que muitas pessoas pensam só em conteúdo
esquecem da distribuição mas produzir
conteúdo e distribuir conteúdo não é
suficiente
você precisa dar um passo
mas você se engajar nessa luta você tem
que criar um conteúdo você tem que
distribuir seu conteúdo você precisa
engaja serão depois quando chegou nele a
poder olhar pra isso entender que aquilo
é importante e continuar engajado com
aquele conteúdo durante às vezes um mês
às vezes seis meses às vezes um ano às
vezes uma vida inteira e por isso você
precisa pensar como é que você pode
melhorar a performance dele e quando se
fala de educação em performance você
pode mais performance essa é a melhor
palavra nós lidamos com o enem
dado que nós começamos lidando com uma
nem performance é assim a palavra nós
precisamos para gerar um impacto na vida
do aluno fazer com que ele tinha uma
nota maior no enem
nós precisávamos e precisamos ainda
melhorar a performance dele com 7
milhões de alunos fazendo o enem
essa arquitetura por mais simples que
possa parecer uma arquitetura que
funciona produzir conteúdo distribuir
conteúdo engajar os alunos melhorar a
performance do lado isso pode receber os
atores disso ele é um ator só são muitos
atores com as principais células não
pode simplificar isso com quatro atores
principais pode os estudantes os
professores gestores sejam eles
diretores coordenadores todo tipo de
gestores e os pais dos alunos
e aí você chega então alguns estudantes
professores gestores e pais de um lado
conteúdo distribuição engajamento e
performance do outro num modelo que você
tem muitas combinações e é importante
escolher onde vai começar
nós fizemos uma escolha por um de nós
vamos começar nós vamos começar
produzindo conteúdo distribuído engajam
melhorando a performance de estudante
foi o que nós começamos a fazer há três
anos atrás é isso que estamos fazendo
até hoje dando cada vez mais escala para
resolver um problema sério a educação
não pode ajudar todo mundo resolver um
problema podemos resolver muitos
problemas mas será que podemos escolher
um sabe podemos fazer mais simples
começar por uma coisa assim róbson e foi
quem escolheu fazer resolver um problema
grande que a melhoria de performance e
nem com 7 milhões de alunos
mais de sete milhões de alunos se
inscreveram na prova e quantidade de
vagas que tem hoje no brasil conseguiu
entrar na universidade no brasil um jogo
bem difícil de ganhar
é um jogo muito difícil ganhar aqui pra
mim foi muito difícil ganhar
eu sei o quanto é difícil tendo passado
por escolas públicas a vida inteira
nós temos um modelo que não vou nem
perder muito tempo porque todo mundo
aqui sabe disso mas é importante repetir
a gente lembrar que se você tem muita
grana preparação muito boa num cursinho
eo jogo ficou mais fácil ganhar
se você não tem grana nenhuma para se
preparar bem esse jogo é quase
impossível de ganhar com a mudança o
jogo serve para revelar um pouquinho
isso é que dá pra colocar todo mundo pra
eu detesto a palavra mas a palavra é
essa competir em igualdade de condições
a resposta é sim de maneira simples nós
podemos resolver um problema nós podemos
resolver o problema nós podemos ajudar a
resolver esse problema
passo a passo o pneu como é que se
resolve o conteúdo é mais um problema de
conteúdo como não consigo fazer com esse
conteúdo existir para chegar às pessoas
ele começou a perguntar se nós é muito
bom fazer esse você tem se você é
importante livro brasil que você quiser
você coloca 30 coisas do papel esse e
sim o que ele pensou foi preciso
conseguir filmar todo o conteúdo do
ensino médio tudo tudo o primeiro ano o
2º ou 3º ano
todas as aulas tudo e se nós
conseguirmos formar tudo e colocar
disponível precisa longe e se nós
conseguirmos formar toda teoria isso nós
conseguimos tomar todos os exemplos
possíveis todas as competições possíveis
pelos exercícios possível colocar em
vídeos gravados e deixar só os
assistirem
se não conseguirmos fazer isso é mais
fácil do que parece
a maioria das coisas são mais fáceis do
que parece que você coloca uma grande na
frente
nós começamos a filmar fomos 10 100 500
filmamos mil 2 mil 3 mil 4 mil 5 mil
hoje nós temos 6.000 vídeo pré gravado e
está muito perto de tudo tá muito perto
de chegar lá e se estamos começando a
pensar em outros e se nós começamos a
filmar esses vídeos e colocamos colar
começamos a colocar seus vídeos gravados
disponíveis e começamos a perceber que
tem outros problemas problemas de
procrastinação prova de engajamento como
o aluno vídeo gravado vou ver amanhã eu
vou ver amanhã vou ver amanhã o amanhã
nunca chega
e se nós pudéssemos fazer o vivo nós
começamos fazer ao vivo uma vez por mês
depois uma vez por semana depois duas
vezes por semana e hoje nós fazemos
fazemos ao vivo
não vivo online todo dia duas vezes por
dia
chegamos a atingir mais de 115 mil
alunos em uma aula e se a gente
conseguisse atingir milhões de pessoas
mal
nós chegamos a 115 mil feras vão
conseguir um milhão
esse é o nosso trabalho é o nosso
desafio e quando você pensa em conteúdo
não basta só pensar em fazer um vídeo
colocar o vídeo pré-gravado vou colocar
ao vivo e como é que você contextualiza
a isso e nós pensamos em si nós
pudéssemos contextualizar isso e se nós
pudéssemos sair um pouquinho de sala de
aula
isso começou a sair da sala de aula a
gente segue sala de aula com o professor
fernando amaral agora cônsul gravações
no deserto do saara essa inclusive é uma
das nossas trabalha com marketing ela
fez uma gravação 100 de conteúdo
ela estava ali e o contexto é muito
importante e se nós conseguirmos fazer
isso em seus próximos o pantanal e seus
bonecos aplicativo expressamos
contextualizar todo o ensino médio
são mais desejáveis é mais fácil do que
parece
é só o primeiro passo é consistente nos
passos que você dá mas depois começamos
a perguntar isso além do contexto nós
pudéssemos colocar isso de maneira
multidisciplinar
porque quando você vai procurar dar mal
você pode encontrar uma aula de biologia
e geografia para falar com muita
história pra falar
e foi isso que nós fizemos o editorial
são três professores numa balsa no
pantanal professor de biologia um
professor de história e um professor de
geografia aula nem de biologia e
história resolveu é uma aula sobre tudo
o que pode ser aprendido ali naquele
contexto
naquele ecossistema de professor de
história professor de geografia
professor de biologia e os professores
porque eu to nesse espaço há 17 anos eu
já vi muita coisa cantando do ser
iniciada nesse espaço e um problema que
eu sempre vi foi que a partir de um
projeto novo à a bola o professor vai
ser editor há agora o professor vai ser
locutor
agora o professor vai ser ator agora o
professor vai ser roteirista agora o
professor vai ser blogueiro
o professor pode ser professor sabino
silva pedindo o professor fazer coisa
demais sem dar nenhuma ferramenta de uma
capacitação para ele não ver se do dia
para noite professora verá roteirista
blogueiro
botou o editor editor de texto editores
de vídeo deixa ele ser professor cria um
contexto em que o professor possa fazer
o melhor do que ele sabe fazer e não uma
coisa completamente diferente que nunca
fiz na vida
desafios são interessantíssimos desafios
sempre ótimos e todo mundo gosta de
desafios quando eles são muito um
pouquinho desafiadores mas são
conquistáveis vamos ter um pouquinho
mais de cuidado para deixar os desafios
conquistáveis não pedi pra de repente
centenas milhares de professores no país
inteiro faz outra coisa que já fizeram
antes
vamos dar um passo de cada vez um pouco
mais de consistência e seu conteúdo
então começou a ficar resolvido esse é
um dos meus três anos nós começamos a
resolver conteúdo isso sozinho não
teremos novamente nada se junto com o
desenvolvimento de conteúdo nós não
fizéssemos também o envolvimento de
distribuição nós e para vós e filmar o
vídeo sangue vai ver não adianta nada
você demora ao vivo online maravilhosa
uma audiência zero ou levar três
professoras o pantanal e voltaram saber
o que fazer com que o como você
distribui isso e aí o é claro que abriu
o primeiro passo algumas tribos na
internet o ministro usou a web não é tão
simples assim
nós criamos uma plataforma nós criamos o
descomplica é que o papa nem sobre o
descomplica que funcionou ficou mais do
que provado que é possível ganhar muito
escala no nosso primeiro ano já
atingimos 570 mil alunos é um só e de
meio milhão de alunos
esse é o sonho dos ativos 570 mil alunos
do primeiro ano no segundo 11 temos um
milhão e 40 mil alunos do 3º ano foi a
do ano passado quando atingiu us 3
milhões 168 mil 287 e se a gente
conseguisse atingir 10 milhões
a gente continua perguntando o que
acontece que tipo de impacto pode gerar
mas não adianta esperar que todo mundo
cheio de gente tá é importante criar
espaços e não só que as próximas estarão
espaços em que o aluno já está a ocupar
espaços que o aluno ocupa e não podia
simplesmente para o aluno ocupar o
espaço que nós estamos confortavelmente
o pão e nós começamos a fazer coisas no
youtube
nós começamos a fazer coisas no facebook
nós começamos a entregar conteúdo dos
espaços que os alunos estão ocupando mas
isso não é suficiente
não adianta trabalhar só na internet
porque existe um problema de
infraestrutura é muito grande no brasil
não adianta você parar pra
pensar que você só vai funcionar se você
conseguir fazer com que o aluno tem
banda larga em se nós conseguirmos levar
conteúdo problema que não têm banda
larga
quando você faz as perguntas não
necessariamente uma alta tecnologia que
resolve você pode distribuir conteúdo
banca de verão
nós distribuímos quase 200 mil dvds em
banca de jornal não têm banda larga
você consegue fazer o conteúdo chegar
lhe ensina a expressão distribuir o
conteúdo dos cenários nas mais de 200
mil alunos já receberam conteúdo nosso
via celular
você não pode ficar preso num espaço em
que você está
você não pode querer um em concreto no
teu pé ficar parado ali o tempo inteiro
você precisa andar um pouco você precisa
sair literalmente locais até agora sair
dessa zona que na teoria você deveria
ficar e chegar um pouco mais perto do
lugar isso é difuso e e abstratos e
sánchez concreto na prática uma lista
quais são os espaços em que sou aluno
ocupa quais são os passos de seus alunos
estão hoje vivemos esteja ó também mas
agora não adianta nada produzem o melhor
conteúdo do mundo conseguiu a melhor
distribuição do mundo senão da playtv 30
segundos separam mas eu sou grande lago
você precisa criar conteúdo distribuir o
conteúdo e engajar o aluno sem
engajamento nada funciona
eles param durante muito tempo pensava
em como poderia ficar um pouco mais
engajada como nós poderemos engajar-se
aluno ea resposta simples é diversão
você chega mais engajada como você está
se divertindo
o que pode ser mais um jogador do que
uma aula que é divertida a nossa missão
era receber comentários do tipo eu nunca
na minha vida e tanto numa aula de
biologia
o melhor comentário que a gente pode
receber eu nunca pensei que pudesse me
divertindo uma aula de matemática porque
quando você faz o aluno se divertir você
faz voltar a fazer o que o professor tem
que ser um palhaço em um comediante mas
o engajamento passa muito por diversão
passa muito por achar que aquilo é
bacana divertido e não somente útil
pior ainda quando é inútil e todo mundo
sabe disso e mais que diversão às
pessoas que era mais fácil de jogos ao
vivo mesmo com o line
mesmo que eu era ao vivo nós começamos a
bola eu já falei um pouco uma vez
mais uma vez por semana passamos a fazer
todo dia e chegamos nada mal começamos a
dar outras qualidades
os professores literalmente nas
primeiras aulas literalmente a mas como
é que a infraestrutura necessária
infraestrutura necessária ao seu foco à
minha casa e uma câmera linha dessa
forma melhora da qualidade dos
professores são paulo só da minha casa
com internet na minha casa com uma
câmera pequenininho
eles literalmente abrir um jornal é
exatamente isso que aconteceu comecei a
olhar as notícias e vamos começar a
dialogar
estamos num momento muito estranho aqui
porque nós vamos falar sobre o futuro da
educação sobre a revolução isso aqui é
supertradicional eu tenho um pé rapado
eu tô falando você está vendo essa coisa
funciona
então nós não precisamos que não era
tudo que foi feito e fazer uma coisa
totalmente nova
o objetivo não é revolucionário o
objetivo é melhorar a vida das pessoas
se nós não vivemos nós precisamos de uma
revolução nessa primeira coisa que vai
fazer se nós entendemos que nós não
precisamos de uma revolução não
precisamos de uma revolução
nós precisamos produzir conteúdo melhor
nós precisamos distribuir melhor
nós precisamos engajar mais nossos
alunos nós vamos aumentar a performance
dele
nós conseguimos nada houve mais 115 mil
alunos numa aula ao vivo funciona
espero 12 horas na gala o autor ou todi
se nós fizéssemos mais de 12 horas
então quando distribuição engajamento
para esses alunos porque a gente começou
a resolver ea pergunta é mais reformas
o que você vai fazer para melhorar a
performance o que fazer com ela forma já
disse que vou fazer não vou pensar na
performance o que vou fazer o melhor
para formas a garantir o conteúdo
funcional é garantir que a distribuição
foi bom é garantir que os alunos se
engaja performance vem naturalmente
eu já cansei de bastad reuniões de
reuniões de performance e se hoje parece
olhar para formas de olhar só para o
conteúdo para distribuição e
planejamento certa forma não vem
automaticamente
a resposta é sim nós somos performa
média bastante melhor do que os outros
brasil 78% dos nossos alunos em média
acima da média nacional nem reformas
aparece nós nunca fizemos uma reunião de
performance
nós fizemos muitas reuniões de conteúdo
e distribuição de engajamento não faltam
ideias e 10 pontos de cultura já isso
foi falado aqui aqui suas idéias aqui
estamos 12 idéias as idéias acontece o
tempo inteiro é só olhar pro outro e vai
ter 10 e 10/5 idéias 2010 50 e 10 mas
faltam modelos escaláveis replicáveis de
impacto falta fazer nossas afegã tesco
nosso desafio é enorme por um motivo
simples da vida os professores éramos o
professor
o desafio do professor e quando digo nós
nos desafios complicados o fim dos
professores da educação porque nós
simplesmente viramos com os alunos e
fomos fazer isso assim que você entendeu
isso é incrivelmente difícil de fazer
virar um aluno sem ter noção de qual vai
ser a resposta e pergunta pra ele o que
você entendeu não se impede que você
pode ver não sei como vou reagir
esse é um desafio muito grande quanto o
problema é que esse é um desafio
gigantesco mas que nós avançamos desafio
aqui não há pausas para todos nós
começamos esse desafio
esse desafio gigantesco deverá ouvir
falar quanto o problema que não entendeu
e você quer mas fazemos todo dia com
professores ou como gestores ou como
python com instituições de ensino
esse desafio é muito muito grande eu
queria terminar com uma frase que é o
que eu gosto muito da festa é bastante
difícil na frança que demorei um pouco
para entender para falar a verdade
vou deixar aqui um tempinho eu demorei
um pouco para entender isso
a frase do cocô impossível não é a
proximidade das coisas mas lukaku que
elas podem ser vizinho é fácil você
pensar em 30 coisa diferente
e pensar que elas podem ser próximos mas
pensar isso
o difícil não é impossível não
a fase é impossível mas é difícil não
pensar na proximidade das coisas
o difícil é criar um lugar em que elas
podem ser presente
esse é o nosso desafio é isso que nós
fazemos nós criamos assembléia